arlette chabot fr3 propos de sa famille
à propos de l'opposition toujours celle
ci semble absolument assuré de gagner
législatives je pense que vous ne
partagez peut-être pas ce sentiment mais
trouvez vous que vos amis socialistes se
battent avec à cette force et que pensez
vous mêmes de leurs idées de débaptiser
le ps c'est de le transformer en parti
social démocrate le parti socialiste de
plus que moi je suis je suis social et
je suis pas dirigeant du parti suisse
puisque je ne suis plus je reste l'ami
des socialistes et de leurs dirigeants
s'il me demandait mon avis ou nos jours
il me demande d'ailleurs pierre mauroy
quand même entretenu cela hier soir je
leur déconseiller le parti socialiste
tel qu'il est tel qu'on le connaît c'est
un parti de liberté que dans le discours
il ajoute démocratique pourrait être
quatre points sur le mammy je veux bien
mais le parti sur le parti socialiste
c'est en tout cas comme ça je le sens
faut pas avoir peur de ce que l'on n'est
pas craindre une histoire faire
confiance à son avenir
ça représente une telle somme de
sacrifice est idéal pourquoi laisser ça
aux bordelaises maxence là dès sa
formation politique y compris à celle là
sera comme elle voudra